i'm here with iman l sheikh khan
academy's world history fellow
and the question i have iman is history
often focuses on men but clearly women
were playing a significant role but how
much can we know about women say 2 000
years ago so when we talk about the
lives of women in
the classical period sometimes we're
tempted to compare it to the modern day
and that can cause some problems because
that's not really a fair comparison so
it's more useful to see how different
women living in different societies at
the same time period compared to one
another that can make their differences
a lot more salient and give us a better
idea of course it's it's hard to know
the history of women back then in
general we don't necessarily have all
the best sources but we can try to piece
together some understanding of what
their daily lives were like and we have
two points of reference here one from
rome as it transitions from republic to
empire and another from han china so
let's look at the reference from rome so
just for a little bit of context this
speech that we're going to talk about
this occurs in 42 bce people might
remember that in 44 bce you have julius
caesar getting assassinated on the ides
of march and it throws the roman empire
into a civil war and so this speech is
given during that civil war because
civil wars they're not just bloody
they're also expensive and to fund that
civil war the triumvirs decide to tax
the 1400 wealthiest women and hortensia
who gives a speech is one of those
wealthy women
ortentia says
why should we pay taxes when we do not
share in the offices honors military
commands nor in short the government for
which you fight between yourselves with
such harmful results you say because it
is wartime when has there not been war
and when have women pay taxes by nature
of their sex women are absolved from
paying taxes among all mankind
our mothers did once rise superior to
their sex and made contributions when
you face the loss of the empire and the
city itself through the conflict with
the carthaginians but they funded their
contributions voluntarily from their
jewelry not from their landed property
their fields their dowries or their
houses without which is it is impossible
for free women to live
let war with the council parthians come
we will not be inferior to our mothers
when it is a question of common safety
but for civil wars may we never
contribute nor aid you against each
other we did not pay taxes to caesar or
to pompeii nor did marius ask us for
contributions nor sinnah nor sulla even
though he was a tyrant over this country
and you say that you are re-establishing
the republic
wow that was quite powerful and there's
a lot of richness here
what's your takeaway
so it's interesting that she is saying
that by nature of their sex women are
absolved from paying taxes and it might
seem like she's saying that women are
weaker but she's sort of speaking back
to
um
this this requirement that they should
use their property because they're
normally using jewelry and they're
normally using things that they don't
necessarily need in order to fight off
foreigners and here she's really taking
issue with uh having to use her
livelihood to support a civil war and
she's sort of taking them to task on
this that they're they're worse than the
tyrants for asking this of her
and the other thing that jumps out of
this it comes out of the first few
statements why should we pay taxes when
we do not share in the office's honors
military commands nor short the
government so she's making very clear
like women don't get to participate why
should we fund this war i also like this
part you say because it is wartime when
has there not been war that's a really
good point because rome especially at
that point was it continuously
conquering other peoples continuously at
war sometimes a civil war sometimes an
external war sure and and i think it's
it's interesting how she's pointing to
that disparity between the things that
men have and women don't have and she's
just trying to say well if that's how
it's going to be then we should also be
exempt from taxation um and i think
that's an interesting way to
to voice uh concerns and and while this
might seem very
primitive to our modern sensibilities
it's really powerful that a woman is is
taking these government officials to
task and being so outspoken and quite
scathing and the way she does this i
also like this second part right over
here where she is citing that our
mothers once also stepped up and she was
referring to during the second punic war
and hannibal was running amok on the
italian peninsula and even threatening
rome itself that the women of rome
especially the wealthy women of rome did
step up and pay taxes so based on this
cell what do you think uh we can learn
about roman women and and their lives at
this time period
well as we pointed out even in this
speech she cites some direct reference
to not having equality to men
but on the other hand she has stormed
the triumvirs tribunal i think this is
the first time that women were well they
weren't even allowed there they just
went there and she's sticking it to the
triumvirs pretty strongly she's saying
let war with the celts or parthians come
we will not be inferior to our mothers
we're willing to step up if it's a war
with external parties but for civil wars
may we never contribute nor aid you
against each other they're saying hey if
you want to fight yourself that's your
problem and she's even telling them and
you say that you are re-establishing the
republic so she's questioning the three
most powerful people in the roman empire
she's questioning their their very
intentions so it does show at least
culturally even if officially women do
not have a strong role at least these
elite women
do have enough comfort to be able to go
to the three most powerful in the roman
empire and and stick it to them yeah and
this is you know while this might not
seem like a big deal to us now we have
to sort of avoid that comparison like i
said and if we compare it to some other
societies around the same time this is
quite remarkable for a woman to enter a
public institution and again she is an
elite woman but let's compare it to say
athenian women even elite women in
athens were not likely to have any
involvement in the political
institutions were a lot more likely to
just remain in the private sphere um
we're not likely to be as educated as
roman women and so the fact that
hortensia can actually enter into the
space and be so outspoken is sort of
evidence of the fact that roman women
had a degree more freedom than other
women who were their contemporaries in
other societies absolutely and let's
continue that comparison we can go about
100 150 years further in the future from
hortentius beach and let's also go to
the other side of almost the other side
of the world we'll go to eastern asia
where we are in the eastern han dynasty
so here we have some text from bon zhao
who was a female historian astronomer
mathematician confucian philosopher
co-author of the history the official
history book of han and it's from her
lessons for women so ban zhao says
let a woman modestly yield to others let
her respect others let her put others
first herself last
lay the girl baby at birth below the bed
to plainly indicate that she is lowly
and weak and should regard it as her
primary duty to humble herself before
others a husband can marry twice but his
wife must never remarry just as heaven
cannot be disobeyed so the wife cannot
keep away from her husband
man is honored for strength a woman is
beautiful on account of her gentleness
so what's your take on that
so this is you know very much in line
with the confucian ideal of womanhood
and that's very much about a woman being
very submissive to her male relatives
and
for
her to stay very modest within the the
power framework of her society and to
stay pretty much within her own
household and to cultivate a life that
is meant to
create comfort for the men and her
family and and her children and not much
more than that
yeah i could not imagine anyone who read
this and took it seriously as viewing a
lesson for themselves as storming the
triumvirs tribunals even if they're an
elite woman in imperial china
certainly but i think there's an
important thing to remember and that
this kind of document shows a sort of
prescriptive approach to women's lives
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
women did live this way i mean the fact
that ban zhao herself is writing this is
sort of ironic because she's a woman who
is putting herself out there and writing
things and not staying in the private
sphere so that's sort of a strange
contradiction there but also um women
who had a lot of wealth were likely to
become educated like her and also it
sort of depended on their generation uh
older women were likely to have
inheritances property just like their
roman counterparts and they were more
likely to engage in trade and we can
find this out by looking at other
documents like wills and so forth so we
can sort of see a tension between the
sort of prescriptive confucian ideals
and how women actually lived and in a
lot of ways having uh
having wealth allowed women to buy their
their way out of these constrictive
practices and ideas about women i
definitely agree with that irony it's
quite thick here because she's telling
other women
to indicate that she is lowly and weak
but ban zhao herself as i mentioned
she's a historian astronomer
mathematician confucian philosopher she
wrote co-wrote one of the official
histories of the han empire
she's more prominent and has done more
than the great majority of men in her
time so she's clearly not lowly and weak
so the irony is quite thick certainly
it's interesting to look at these things
because
like you said it gives us a sense of
the difference right like there seems to
be quite a different culture at play
between rome and china at this time and
so making that kind of comparison gives
us a lot more information about women's
lives than simply saying that there's a
sort of a single history for all women
of this time period and that's simply
not the case as we can see there are
huge differences between the
civilizations certainly even within
civilizations there can be huge
differences yes both of the examples we
looked at have been very elite women
we're talking about women well within
the top one percent if you went to more
average women their situation would have
been very different certainly so this
idea that women are supposed to have a
nice home full of family and and stay
within that well only wealthy women can
really live up to that because if you
have to leave the house to make a living
uh you might not be able to sort of
create this idyllic household full of
children and spend all your time
managing that so that's an important
difference as well thanks iman this was
really valuable thanks sal